well I just feel being away when I'm
away from sound I want to be around it
and almost just sitting down and
knocking out a chord on the piano can be
enough though sometimes I since I am a
reader it can be not something I want
necessary to deal with but which
suggests some world that I'm interested
in could become interested in I like the
company of writers because they're their
world of making things up is so
different from ours it deals with
certain kinds of specifics that I think
are very valuable so I can be inspired
by buy almost anything even just a
change of scenery but inspiration is has
never been difficult for me sometimes
the the more the more difficult thing to
find is and this is probably a deep sort
of early psychic thing is the confidence
that the response to the inspiration is
durable because at a certain point I
have to fight through the questioner
part and I'm much better at teaching or
showing the other composers how to get
through that and I am
doing it myself I have to rub catechized
myself out to talk myself into I think
we're all instilled with various levels
of confidence I've always been
interested in reading benjamin britten
statements a his home most his whole
career is described in terms of level of
confidence you know I wrote that piece i
was on a high level of confidence well
some people have that in great abundance
but others have to call the data like a
garden well it tends to be the very
often the text writer that I'm engaged
with Elizabeth Bishop because I don't
just read the I don't just read the
writings of such a person you know I
find out as much as I can because if
you're working with even six or seven
poems there is so much there that you
need to to absorb and so my kind of life
history of literary friends is probably
where I draw the most excitement and
right now it's going to be whatever next
text i SAT I'm trying to begin to
inhabit it and that means finding out a
lot
fairly unruly and I just try to not
listen to much to all the wonderfully
orderly ways that everyone does things
I've decided everybody works differently
and the fact that I don't have any
routine and never have had it I've just
kind of given up worrying about that
aspect of it I I tend to work in very
unpredictable moments and I'm learning
more and more as I think life gets more
complicated as you get as you go along
you have more things you have to keep
track of I'm learning to honor the very
brief moment that something might happen
I've gone through periods where i know
i'm writing just to keep going but I
don't think I be psychologically capable
of not doing anything I probably will
just write a piece that can be more
executed than the actually fantasy is
the fantasy element gives way somewhat
to knowledge but I would rather do that
than not do anything and it also makes
it makes me appreciate much more you
know those are the pieces there that if
their commissions I feel like I earned
my money and sometimes if I have a
commission and I am in a very wide open
and immediate and apprehend I'm
apprehending things easily I when I get
the money i think my gosh I didn't even
earn this but then I think it evens out
it I'm probably my fee schedule is
probably based on the average in terms
of these work experiences